[Musique]
un 15 août sur la croisette à cannes
c'est le parcours du combattant
le calme la tranquillité ce n'est pas
ici mais peut-être ce n'est pas si loin
les îles de lérins sont posés seulement
à un jet de pierre de la côte cannoise
pourtant elle serait la promesse d'une
évasion inespéré un havre de paix un
cadre idyllique à la nature protéger et
préserver la grande sainte marguerite et
la petite saint-honorat sont deux îles
soeurs ont dit qu'elles sont
exceptionnelles
chacune avec un caractère bien
particulier
[Musique]
à peine dix minutes de traversée pour se
rendre sur l'île sainte marguerite
[Musique]
et pour une visite guidée originale nous
avons demandé à frédéric de nous faire
découvrir à sainte-marguerite un monde à
part
[Musique]
un pointu c'est encore un des rares
bateaux à pêcher il ya du monde oui mais
ça fera du bien quand même c'est bon
enfant
ça a publi
qui part en voyage
si c'est un tout petit voyage sur un
tout petit bout du monde
[Musique]
pour échapper à la foule il va falloir
prendre les chemins de traverse
[Musique]
cela tombe bien frédéric sait dénicher
les coins secrets qui font toute la
magie de lille je vais vous montrer un
coin de paradis
le cabanon rêver
avec le ponton et vue sur cannes
magnifique la plus belle qui soit quelle
chance quelle chance
[Musique]
il n'y a pas d' habitants sur l'île
seuls quelques privilégiés ont un droit
de location l'été sur ses anciens
cabanes de pêcheurs
héritant ainsi d'une sainte marguerite
authentique
[Musique]
c'est ce qu'elle apprécie frédéric
toutes ces vieilles pierres cachées ici
et là qui vous font traverser les
époques
à la voir il a été restitués récemment
seul à voir mais il est sur les plans du
xviie il était frédéric aime parler
d'histoire elle est la conservatrice du
musée du fort royal de sainte marguerite
pour y accéder il faut grimper un long
escalier 260 marche avec au bout la
récompense de pénétrer dans un tout
autre univers
[Musique]
rénové par vauban au xviie siècle le
fort militaire de sainte-marguerite
devient une prison d'état cinq cellules
sont réservés aux prisonniers
personnellement désigné par le roi
dans l'une d'entre elle un ami a été
enfermé pendant onze ans sous silence le
visage caché par un masque de fer frère
jumeau amants de la reine ministre
gênant ou simple valet qui était cet
homme mystérieux depuis le xviie on ne
fait que parler du masque de fer
on ne sait toujours pas qui c'est
pas du tout le soleil c'est sa mort crie
beaucoup je trouve c'est du barreau
d'époque 1 17e depuis toujours l'énigme
de l'homme au masque de fer excite les
imaginations conspiration vengeance
affaire d'état tout semble possible
les visiteurs viennent pour sas
apportent leurs rêves ça leur donne
envie de rencontre et l'histoire me rêve
il rêve du complot il rêve du complot
d'état d'un homme brisé du masque de fer
c'est étonnant c'est qu'on voit beaucoup
aussi en italie des musées des musées
qui montre le goût de la torture pour le
moyen-âge ben c'est un peu de cet ordre
là
[Musique]
lorsque certains aiment se plonger dans
les mystères de l'histoire
d'autres préfèrent s'évader à la
recherche de la criques désertes et d'un
semblant de vie sauvage
mais aujourd'hui ce n'est pas gagné
[Musique]
situé entre les deux îles de lérins
cette zone de mouillage l'été est prise
d'assaut
tant mieux pour marlène qui depuis neuf
ans propose glace sandwiches et boissons
fraîches à l'abordage
puis son gros et puis guaino mig et bien
pour les bois
[Musique]
alors qu'est ce qu'ils nous ont confié
un coco kojima grougi bre.un compagnie
et moi alors une coco 1 comme vanille
vous venez chercher quoi ici du bonheur
surtout rire beaucoup de bonheur malgré
le monde
c'est par là qu'on adore la cotation
c'est vrai que c'est un cadran vraiment
dans mon magnifique voix
travail est sympa et travailler en mer
comme ça toute la journée je changerais
ça pour un moment
un véritable paradis pour petits et
grands
le temps d'une journée ici la magie des
lieux opère et chacun y trouve son
compte
le calme surtout les eaux turquoises et
puis c'est vrai que la tranquillité on
n'est pas les uns sur les autres comme
sur la plage comme on a cet avantage les
personnes juste en face de
sainte-marguerite l'île saint-honorat
est une tout autre ambiance
lille est un domaine privé qui
appartient à des moines
[Musique]
ce sont des cisterciens qui vivent selon
la règle de saint benoît
[Musique]
un temps pour le recueillement un temps
pour le travail
un temps pour le repos selon un rythme
très précis et immuable une philosophie
de vie qui permettrait d'accéder à
l'harmonie et la sérénité
on peut venir à saint-honorat pour la
journée ou bien pourquoi pas faire un
séjour en immersion totale dans l'une
des chambres du monastère j'aimerais
vous demander le plus simple vraiment et
viennent à laisser sa maison de 300 m²
son mari et ses enfants pour se
ressourcer ici pendant un mois j'ai mon
petit déjeuner alors j'ai emmené mes 21
ans j'ai emmené pour vous c'est pour mes
enfants j'ai mon petit pot de nutella
j'ai emmené mes craintes côte j'ai
compté j'ai droit à deux grappes par
jour pas plus lui 2 gr co2 par jour
j'ai mon plateau alors je prends mon
couteau vous faisais moi comment je mets
procès je le mets dessus parce que
j'aime vers l'aquarelle aussi je suis
ici et je déjeune en silence
j'ai besoin du d'événements à une petite
pièce l'essentiel vraiment l'essentiel
est là je fais bien le contraste de ce
qui est important dans la vie au
monastère de l'abbaye de lérins
on suit le rythme des moines on parle
tout bas on médite on goûte au silence
la nature s'impose majestueuse 8
hectares de vignes des oliviers
millénaires
seize siècles d'histoire monastique et
le temps qui semble s'être arrêté
pourtant derrière les murs on s'agite
des bénévoles font office de guide
touristique d'autres à la boutique
vendre les vins les liqueurs et lui le
produit par les moines pour récolter des
fonds nécessaires à la vie sur l'île
la communauté de l'abbaye se veut active
et dynamique ouverte sur le monde
extérieur
la preuve ce restaurant propriété des
moines est digne des plus grands
établissements de la croisette à cannes
sept personnes en cuisine pour arriver à
faire 350 400 couverts tous les midis
car maman marque du soulier et le gérant
de cette unique restaurant sur l'île
c'est la frite autant de gourmandises à
quelques pas du monastère est ce bien
raisonnable
surtout qu'ici il faut pouvoir établir
une carte qui s'adresse aussi bien aux
pèlerins de passage copropriétaire des
yachts amarrés juste en face
[Musique]
on veut pas dire c'est un restaurant
cher ou c'est un restaurant qui est
abordable
d'un autre côté une clientèle qui bien
qu'à un fort pouvoir d'achat il faut
leur donner un produit qui correspond un
peu ce qu'ils attendent donc simple que
cette mixité qui est intéressante et
l'équation aller là c'est le choix de
l'abbaye d' d'avoir et d'autres faits
aussi aujourd'hui d'arriver à avoir un
produit qui convient tout de même sur
l'île c'est le frère marié pâques qui
gère les finances rentabilité recettes
bénéfices le monde de l'entreprise n'a
plus aucun secret pour lui un véritable
businessman
mais selon lui on peut faire des
affaires tout en gardant une approche
fraternelle et l'a même écrit un livre
sur le sujet dans le livre je montre que
les affaires sont nécessaires au monde
d'aujourd'hui est que ce capitalisme est
une belle et bonne chose la seule chose
qu'on peut lui reprocher ses excès et
qu'il faut effectivement le
le canaliser le légiférer pour que
on puisse
puisse être au service du plus grand
nombre du bien commun paradoxalement
j'ai un coeur pully mois sur ce qu'est
la charité c'est à dire le don de soi
gratuit des intéressés aux plus fragiles
sans rien attendre en retour
li avec le la création de richesses et
c'est possible je pense que c'est même
indispensable faire de l'entreprise un
lieu d'amour et de fraternité c'est le
credo de frères maris pack qui échangent
avec de nombreux grands patrons en quête
de sens
je rencontre des dirigeants d'entreprise
une question que je leur pose
aimez vous vos collaborateurs c'est sûr
que ça détonne
en attendant l'abbaye de lérins est une
véritable petite entreprise au succès
grandissant et le frère marié pâques un
incroyable gérant de plusieurs sociétés
dont la commercialisation des vins de
lérins chine russie etats unis on se les
arrache au prix fort et le frère
parcourt le monde pour relever les reims
au rang d'une marque internationale
retour sur l'île de sainte marguerite
pour une toute autre mission
[Musique]
elysée vallès et le responsable de
l'office national des forêts il vit sur
l'île et chaque jour il protège la
nature de la pression humaine et
touristique
[Musique]
bonjour vous pouvez peut-être aussi
gratuit
je vous remercie bonne journée
jour telle une ombre elysées surveille
chaque personne qui pose un pied dans
son jardin discrètement il délimite son
territoire avec des barrières protège
les plantations avec des pierres qui se
fondent dans le décor
il aménage des aires de repos des points
de vue pour empêcher le touriste de
pénétrer dans les zones naturelles et
préservé bref il éparpille la foule
façon puzzle
[Musique]
un peu de mon nom c'est toute la
difficulté de les embêter de trop et
même jusque dans les profondeurs de la
forêt de sainte marguerite elysée a
planté d'immenses parasols pour inciter
le promeneur à rester dans les allées il
ya très peu de sentiers on s'appuie sur
un réseau de 22 kilomètres d'allées les
allées elles sont confortables bien
nombre est hélas les jeunes se baladait
effectivement une atmosphère de sérénité
c'est rassurant pour moi j'ai fabriqué
ici d ambiance rassurante pour que les
gens j'ai pas envie de rentrer là dedans
pas envie de rentrer à l'hôtel en
restera là
les gens sont libres d'aller où ils
veulent et il se trouve qu'ils restent
sur les allées on n'a pas demandé
d'autre chose
[Musique]
dépeint des eucalyptus les plus anciens
d'europe 170 hectares d'essences
méditerranéennes datant des années 1800
des années de travail pour conserver
cette forêt intacte la préserver des
intempéries et des dégâts de l'homme
[Musique]
ici et là on est sur l'île on n'est
nulle part sur l'île on ne sait pas où
on est d'ailleurs juste à proximité on a
le lis de mer le liste de meilleurs
c'est une plante qui est relativement
rare sur le continent là on l'a on va le
retrouver en bordure de chemin
né à côté de l'endroit où va passer
peut-être 1000 à 1500 personnes par jour
ça c'est une satisfaction énorme de voir
que les gens ne s'approprie pas par des
cueillettes sauvages je suis une plainte
qui relativement agréable avoir à l'oeil
quoi quoi on peut faire confiance aux
jeunes cela fait trente ans qu'elle lise
et vallès oeuvre sur l'île sainte
marguerite
sans tambour ni trompette moi je me
lasse jamais des paysages qui sont sur
l'île s'est il sonne tous exceptionnels
dont un qui mérite tous le coup d'oeil
et puis après on fonctionnait la
luminosité
c'est toujours quelque chose à découvrir
ou à redécouvrir avec plaisir elise est
peut être fier de son grand jardin
il est le plus visité de france avec
cinq cent mille visiteurs par an
[Musique]
une dernière ronde encore élise et
veille à ce qu'il n'ait aucun
retardataire pour le dernier bateau du
soir mais nous pour le retour on s'offre
une dernière virée la communauté de
l'abbaye de lérins est aussi
propriétaire d'une compagnie de bateaux
elle propose une sortie en mer pour une
croisière cocktail des plus chics aux
lueurs du coucher du soleil
en attendant le feu d'artifice tiré au
large de cannes en pleine mer on s'offre
le luxe de goûter au célèbre vin des
moines un mélange des genres tu édifiant
unique et insolite
c'est peut-être ça la magie des îles de
lérins une terre de contrastes où chacun
s'exprime librement et sans façon